i am now all right thank you um
it's uh it's 9 31 on monday the 22nd
2021 and uh as
chair of division three of the house
finance committee i find that due to the
state of emergency declared by the
governor
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic and
in accordance with the governor's
emergency order number 12
which was pursuant to executive order
2020-04 as extended
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
please note that there is no physical
location to observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting which was authorized pursuant to
the governor's emergency order
however in accordance with the emergency
order i'm confirming
uh several things we
are providing access to the meeting to
the public by telephone
and by a zoom the committee is using
zoom for this remote meeting all members
of the committee and the staff estate
agencies with agenda items have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through the platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously watch and or listen to
the meeting
on zoom or they could use the telephone
following the directions and links
provided in the house calendar starting
with house calendar eight going through
house calendar 16.
um so as i just mentioned uh the
instructions for
the following is telephonically are in
the house calendar
if you cannot listen in
in real time to what we're doing you're
encouraged to email us at lba
underscore f-i-s-c-a-l
at leg.state.nh.us
and if you're not able to if we do get
an email with
indicating there are problems will
adjourn and
reschedule so so please note that
all votes taken during this meeting will
be done by roll call
uh and with that um representative bean
yes sir representative wallner
representative walner is here and i'm in
my home in concord and i'm alone
representative nordman representative
nordgren
is here in my dining room slash office
in hanover representative rogers
i'm catherine rogers i'm here in concord
in my apartment with my dog romeo
rosanna
i'll come back to him i guess
uh representative edwards i'm in my home
office in auburn
and uh i have my door shut even though i
have family members
in the house and i just called
representative earth
and there he is i'll go back to him
representative eric president home alone
in my home office
sorry i lost track of time
i'm representative bean i'm home i'm at
my home in guildford
my wife is around about
representative weiler is late um
as sex accounted for
one light all right uh thank you for
that
um so let's start off by reviewing
uh the the work plan so so mr ripple
i copied you in on an email earlier this
morning
uh at 6 57
could you could you open that and then
specifically what i'd appreciate
there
okay and can you shrink that a little
bit so that we're just seeing the image
yeah i'm not sure that i can okay
we can scroll all right all right so
um the this morning i'd like to start us
out by
um i i put exec i i guess technically
there's a different name
since we're uh a effectively a
subcommittee of the whole finance
committee but
but we'll use uh the the procedures for
executing bills
um and we'll uh we'll talk about
hp 600 and take a vote
um then to get oriented to where we are
uh in the overall budget process uh mr
ripple has put together a sheet
that shows uh the adjustments that we've
agreed to
based predominantly on votes that we've
already been taken i
i think there might be a line item in
there relative to the a
m expectations but generally those are
reflecting votes we've taken there's a
second sheet that basically shows a
summary of all of that
and that's going to be have to be
updated probably after some votes today
we i'd like us to to specifically
look at the veterans home um
part of the budget the totals and and
plan on what what we want to do with
that
um for a while i thought representative
rogers
uh was going to have an amendment on
section 35
relative to the a m and so i i printed
or i published this before
uh hearing this morning that she does
not have an amendment on
section 35 but she does have one on 34
which is all fine we're going to discuss
some sysc house bill twos i don't think
they're
out of ols maybe they'll be out of ols
this afternoon
we'll we'll see there are several of
them as i understand
but we have enough information where i
think you can discuss them
intelligently uh and then i just wanted
to touch base again
on the 11 or the 12 april meeting
that we're going to have as a division
relative to the new forensic
hospital just to make sure we're sharing
because it's a little unusual i just
want to make sure everyone's on the same
page
we're going to recess at that point
until 2 30 and as i mentioned
before we started the meeting the reason
that i picked 230
is because um representatives
irf and wyler have a county
meeting that they need to go to relative
to the county budgets
uh and they that they should be back by
2 30.
also we've got a number of amendments
that we've asked
ols to produce for us and and
they're they're working on them right
now so hopefully they'll be done by
2 30. we
are going to talk about hb 254.
there's there's a concept there uh that
we'll talk about this afternoon
we'll need an hb2 section to have a
comprehensive discussion so that's why
that's after 2 30 and not this morning
we're going to talk and hopefully vote
on sections
26 and uh and 34
34 discussion could uh take quite a
while
um that that'll be uh between
committee members uh then um
as we looked at the budget and and
deeper into the mmis
um money that was in the operating
budget
uh it seemed like a big chunk of that
ought to be moved over to
sb excuse me hb2 so we'll talk about
that
there's a personnel hb2 to discuss
there's a back of the budget hb2 to
discuss
and then we just have some opportunity
for discussion and votes
if you could go back up mr ripple to
where you can we can see the
words for the tuesday and wednesday
there that's good
so uh because it's in the house calendar
um i have to start the meeting at 9 30
but we'll probably immediately go into
recess at two
to two o'clock on both days and
and we will only meet if we have a
reason to meet
what could cause us to have a reason to
meet well if
in our discussions it it seems to be
clear that we need ols to do some more
work
we would send the work over today for
example
and and then by two o'clock tomorrow
they should have
had time to produce any results that
we've asked them to
and um and i i don't want to be doing
this but these
are these are typical project management
slack days that have been
programmed in here just so that we
absolutely positively know we're going
to be done
by wednesday the 24th and representative
rogers your hand is up
yes um amendment that i have is not to
section 34.
it says it's a amendment to house bill
one
on the funding um on family planning
so i just want to clear that up okay no
that's a good clarification
and and representative erf has one of
those as well
and so so we'll have an opportunity to
take a look at
a couple at least a couple of options
there
so um okay so that's the orientation to
the day
are there other questions about the
i'm not seeing any so um
mr ripple if you could bring up house
so it's while we're waiting for that
i'll just say
that this is one part of
why i like zoom you know
because if we were all sitting in person
in a committee it would be harder
for us to to have a way to make sure
we're all looking at the same document
at the same
time and i was on ways and means and it
was just really hard to follow
where things were that were being
discussed and so i
i like this aspect of zoom so so even
um
i hope that we can maintain this zoom
component because i think it's a very
powerful communication tool
so so that free editorial aside
uh we took testimony on
hb 600 last week
um there was a good discussion i think
you you may recall representative marsh
introducing the bill and
speaking uh at length to it and uh
taking questions
um there there was a
testimony that talked also about
um by anthem saying that they had not
really had an
opportunity to be informed of this issue
and that they had a point of view
that they were paying for this as a
bundled drg
or a bundled service and i i um
i i can i can appreciate that point of
view
but um i think today
uh i'm ready to entertain a motion
to uh otp recommend otp
sorry before you do that did you want to
introduce the amendment
typically you would vote on the you had
an amendment to change the effective
date
typically you would vote on the
amendment first and then on the bill as
amended
oh i thought it was the other way around
but but
okay i i just remembered it the other
way which is not
uncommon for me to be totally backwards
so so welcome representative weiler
um representative bean took a
role earlier and uh
you look busy there sir are you ready to
to be our clerk or do you want
representative bean to continue for a
while
just finding the tally sheets give me a
sec
okay so this was a simple amendment uh
to hb600 you may recall some discussion
of whether or not
60 days was sufficient for the
department to
implement a change and uh kind of the
thing that seemed
to probably take the longest in their
administrative
changes was that they needed to have
some
code in their system
updated and of course when you do that
you have to design it you got to
update it you gotta test it you gotta
verify it and then you gotta cut over
and go live with it
so so they uh dr chorilla
uh asked for 120 days instead of the 60
days
and this bill sponsor as i recall did
not have an
issue with this so so so are you ready
it looks like representative weiler is
still getting
organized so so i'll entertain a motion
to adopt uh amendment ending in zero
eight nine nine h i would move that we
adopt zero eight nine nine h
a second thank you representative bean
is there is there a discussion on this
amendment
representative wallner did you did you
have some i couldn't tell
if you were moving to speak no
i think i'm betting about 80 with your
your movement towards the screen which
is important
uh okay so do you need a second right
now
oh we got one from robert thank you good
um so uh are you are you ready
if you're if you're ready can you call a
roll
okay this is a motion to adopt the
amendment zero eight nine nine
h representative earth yes
representative weiler votes yes
representative bean
yes representative walner
yes representative nordgren
yes representative rogers
yes representative edwards yes
mr chairman of the vote is seven to zero
all right
thank you so with that amendment passed
we can look at hb 600 and at this point
we're looking at hp
600 with a i i'd like a motion to
otp a i'd move that we
otp a hb 600
uh is there any discussion let's wait
for
mr ripple to flip us to the hb
and again we wouldn't normally do this
in person but since we can i
i just like it visual information is
okay all right so
with a motion and a second to otpa
i'll i'll add a little discussion i i
got
uh an email i did an email exchange with
ms
sue dunlap i believe it's dunlap not
dunlop
but but in any case
she said to me
that they think
anthem for example is paying for these
testing services
uh under a bundled service rate
and uh i had looked i'd listen to the h
committee hearing and to our own
and that point never stuck out to me
during testimony
maybe the point was made and i just
missed it it's a point i don't think i
would have missed
but to be fair to her and to kind of
complete the record
i just want people to know that she's
she believes
that they're paying for it as a bundle
great
and that we didn't hear that in
testimony so what i told her
was two things will happen today
this will either fail and and she
doesn't need to worry about it or this
will pass
and she can work with the senate
to to get that part of her testimony
uh better understood than than the way i
understood it
so i i think i think that's fair to her
and fair to the insurance companies
and i'm i'm i intend to vote in favor of
otpa on hb600
is there any other question any other
comment
okay uh not seeing any mr clerk would
you
take the role
the vote is ought to pass as amended on
house bill 600
representative earth yes
representative weiler votes yes
representative bean
yes representative wallner
yes representative nordgren
yes representative rogers yes
representative edwards yes
mr chairman of the voters 7-0
uh thank you um so what i think that
means is
is the is division three is forwarding
this to finance so that
finance will uh hold a
will finance have to hold another
meeting on this or can
or will this go straight to a finance
it will go straight to a finance
committee exec session yeah
the finance committee will be executing
all the bills passed by the
various divisions we'll start with
division one division two division three
when we have our exec session probably
this
week okay so just technically so i'm
learning the words here
we we our division didn't execute we
we recommended to the finance committee
to execute
is that that's the correct terminology
all right thank you sir
and thank you for concuring
representative wallner
i saw your head shake so
uh mr ripple if you could
show the division three
document that you did you updated as of
this morning
all right okay i want to start with this
overview document that mr ripple has put
together because it itemizes
a lot of things that we've agreed to and
some things that we've not
uh fully uh discussed
um but the first line item is an
easy one uh so coming off of
uh using as a baseline the governor's
proposed budget we've added
14.5 million this first year
and 14.5 million the second year
to the county cap line we voted on that
seven to nothing uh when we when we
looked at the details
does anyone want to revisit that i think
representative rogers your hand is up
we're going to go through each of these
and talk about each of them to the
extent people want to talk about them so
can this be enlarged i can't read it at
all oh
kevin kevin is it possible to send this
to us in an email so that
i can print it off real quick and write
some notes on
so so let's do that it's 9 53
let's take a a sort of a bio break and
an
ingestion break so that people can look
at this and think about it before we
really get into it
so so let's uh let's take a mile break
until 10 o'clock i have it at 9 53 right
now
and then mr ripple while you're sending
that would you send the second document
sure
you
[Laughter]
um
[Music]
hmm
oh
okay i think
um it's 9 59 but it looks like
everyone's ready to go
so um miss ripple if you could return to
sharing
okay and so for those of you that
worked with me this weekend you'll note
that the date on this version is 322
which is today so so some of these
are going to require a discussion
just just to get get us in sync
so uh we just talked about the first
line there it's not numbered but it's
the
14 and a half million dollar a year line
for
the county cap and uh
i i need to figure out how to
see people and see the document
okay so um is there any discussion on
this i think
i think we we have discussed it and
decided on this
anyone anyone wanting to revisit it
there's okay so the next one the
enhanced f map for development service
and child health insurance program
uh this was a 12 million dollars that
was a
essentially newfound revenue in the
estimate
because of the enhanced f map
being applied to all components of
medicaid and not just the main account
so so this is this 12 million dollar
increase in revenues
for us is is uh
is is basically just getting the dot of
the budget document to reflect
reality so this is kind of a correction
i think to the budget
is there any conversation around the
enhanced fmap being reflected
i'm i'm only able to see like five
people at a time in this view so
representative nordgren i'm not
i'm not seeing you i just don't want to
accidentally miss you if you're waving
your hand
representative waller i just wanted
to check kevin is and er
and representative edwards is that the
um
that's the amount that karen told us
for the enhanced uh yes it is and that's
the number you did actually
vote on that one already last week okay
great thank you
and to be clear that's the number we
voted on
it was
so i figured out how i can see all of
you now by the way so if you just wave
all right so eliminate
uh sysc a one-time transition
costs added to hb2
basically this uh removes 12.3 million
uh in fy23 from the department's budget
uh the note about one-time transition
costs
added to hb2 i think if you look
down there which could you highlight for
us is that the 2.65 million
mr ripple down under hb2 adjustments
for the transition costs yes okay
so don't highlight it right here right
okay
so so so yes uh
the the the documents reflect closing it
in the second year but
the uh the transition costs are things
like
you know mock-balling buildings
retraining people
uh those were in doctor doctor that was
on mr
joy's uh list uh
representative wallner do you have a
question
i do um i wondered if
kevin how are we doing on the amendment
is it
syc amendment is it done
at this point it's it's it's not done i
think i may have received one
component there were nine individual
components and so i've asked ols to draw
them as individual amendments and as one
comprehensive amendment because i didn't
know which you and representative weiler
would want to offer i believe i've
received one
of the nine but i haven't had a chance
to look at it yet so i'm thinking it'll
be this afternoon before we've received
the entire
package
okay so on this section my question
would you really want to be taking
savings and adding in house bill 2
until we have really made our final
decision
on what we're going to do with that
amendment
i i think you're absolutely dead on
there representative wallner
and and and what i'm looking at the way
i'm looking at this document right now
is it's it's it's like an 80 90
good draft but it's good enough for us
to see all in one place
the all the issues we've talked about
and
and so uh mr ripple is prepared to
update this based on any additional
votes and decisions we make today but
this
the the pain is not dry here
thank you i i would just i would like to
see the amendment on
the sununu center before i uh
absolutely and so so before i felt
really firm on these
on these figures and and just just to
flash what i think we'll probably end up
having to do
i i think this issue alone of updating
this document
is probably reason enough for us to plan
on coming back tomorrow afternoon at 2
30 just to
put the finishing touches on things but
but today i'm expecting to get through
you know the
is that does it is that that's clear
uh so your hand is still up but oh
all right so uh let's let's rewind and
try that
again the uh so we
are saying we're shutting down the
sununu center
we're incurring a 12.3 million dollar
savings
in the second year and we're
anticipating
one-time transition costs of 2.6 million
in the first year
in order to facilitate that happening
representative weiler do you do you have
any conversations you've had the most
conversations with mr de joy do you want
to
speak to this at all no i think
i think once we see the uh the separate
parts
that probably we could go over the nine
separate parts which kevin has made the
trouble of
coming in nine separate and then we
could if we don't have any problems with
any of them i'd like to adopt it as one
amendment but when we see it all we'll
be looking at
thank you yes sir yes sir okay so
so this is new uh to about half
of half of us uh as we were looking and
talking
about the mmis line item that's
in the operating budget um and listen
and thinking about what we heard
what it it seems is that
the line item that is funding
the contractors in hb1
that's for legacy systems
to operate while we're phasing in new
systems
and and the idea is that these legacy
should go away and we don't want our
operating budget
to reflect uh a
tremendously high artificial rate
of having two systems running in
parallel
at the same time so so the legacy
systems i think should be reflected
in the operating budget because that's
our go
forward operating plan and and
this would move the legacy maintenance
costs to hb2
under the belief that that's the right
way to treat what it effectively is a
one-time
cost the dollar amounts
there are reflect the
amount of that mmis budget that was
related to writing checks
to the contractors that maintain that
in an ideal world with perfect
accounting information we could just do
a quick
sort and figure out how much of
that money is for the legacy system and
how much of it really is going to have
to
stay in operation after
after the phase phase-in of the new
system in other words
the the 12.4 million probably
is a is more of a hybrid than it should
be ideally of both
legacy costs and ongoing future costs
but we don't have the accounting data
to show what a better split on that
would be
so in talking to kevin and
excuse me mr ripple and miss rounds
uh it just seemed like the cleanest
thing to do was
to just put the whole contractor line in
there
and move it to hb2 um
but there are could be easily different
points of view are there any
so what i'm what i'm not hearing is a
basic
agreement that by moving the contract
line
over to hb2 we're treating it as a
one-time cost and then
due to our lack of visibility in the
cost details
we're going to accept the assumption
that that whole line is
see i think i'm i think i'm saying
things that
people who aren't in i.t should
understand and
but i don't know that i am because i've
dealt with i.t people so much so
is there any confusion about what i'm
saying i i don't want to just assume
agreement when there isn't because i i'm
not explaining it
so so mr weiler or representative weiler
just gave me a thumbs up i think
i think it's understood so uh we're
going to see an hb2
on this this afternoon are we not uh if
yes you will thank you
okay so the next line item
is um the the governor's budget
reflected a pretty significant growth
over the current budget in terms of the
number of personnel
assigned to the department and
um and then looking at the vacancies
uh i went through and um
anticipated that we could reduce 180
of them would that which would still do
two things
if we had it at 180
which was my initial thought on this is
that we would have
left enough vacancies in the department
for them to be able to grow continue to
grow some
and they could grow with some a little
bit of flexibility
and that it was a big enough number to
where
everyone who was hired today could get
their step
increases and promotions and none of
them
would have their positions at risk so
180 was was kind of a in my view
a comfortable number for the department
to keep
growing into albeit at a much slower
rate and at a much lower
ceiling on the ceiling issue
it didn't seem to me to be a big deal
because
we have workforce shortages everywhere
every department is talking about
workforce
shortages i have talked to people in
industry
at hospitals uh everyone is having
workforce shortages
so so that's another way of me saying
i don't think the governor's budget
on personnel was really realistic
because we have such workforce shortages
we could carry that head count on the
books we could budget for
it but because of the workforce shortage
we're never going to hire for it anyways
so so why not have our budget reflect
more reality so that was my thinking on
the 180 number
so for those who would like to know how
i got to 226
based on some discussions in the last 24
hours
there's been a request to
to do the absolute most that division
three can do
to bring the budget to a point where
uh it can be passed 226
i think is is that number i haven't
i haven't done the math or the science
on it but i in my
instinct of instincts of 40 years of
doing this stuff
226 i think is is kind of the
the lowest we can go on the personnel
limbo and so
i this morning i asked mr ripple to
put update the hb2 to reflect 226
instead of 180. so so that's new
information to you
representative weiler because you and i
had talked about 180
and now i'm showing you 226 and kind of
a
public meeting so i apologize for that
but
under given the time pressures were
under i i thought i should
go ahead and take this opportunity to do
that
let me ask you a question go ahead say
you were on mute sir okay um
is are we still having something saying
in the back of the budget that you've
got to cut more things or is this
yes that's the next line that's the next
line
the two lines work together personal
reduction department wide reduction
so i think you're referring to the
second line
all right uh represent representative
rogers your hand was up
and then representative waller when you
were talking about
cutting a hundred people yeah
the department basically said that that
was going to
going to do a lot to hurt the department
226 positions is going to devastate the
department
you might talk about industry and other
departments but here
we're talking about staff that's dealing
with our most vulnerable people in the
state
they're dealing with our children
they're dealing with our elderly
they're dealing with people that have
serious developmental problems
they're dealing with our most vulnerable
and we're trying desperately to get
people
into these jobs and now you want to cut
more of them
i think that what you're doing between
that
and your next item we might as well just
shut the doors at health and human
services
um i i could never vote for this budget
with this in there
and i think that i can speak for a
number of people in our caucus
if what you're saying is that you don't
want a democratic vote
on this budget i think that's what
you're going to get with this
these two items thank you for that i i
i would just point out that the
department is operating
now and that this is leaves them with a
head count greater than what they have
now
so it won't be here years if you do
these things
i i i know it would make their job
more difficult and that they would have
to go back to the drawing board and
really rethink their priorities for
additional head count
and that they may have to go back and
take some head count
that is currently occupied and move it
to something that they consider more
valuable
uh or more value-added like for example
there's 96 people
on the staff of the sununu center that
that's 96 people that could be
reprogrammed
uh to um to fill positions
that i think would have more value to
the state so so it looks like a big
number in isolation but given that it's
more than they have now and that they've
got the 96
um at the sununu center that we're
trying to free up
it's it's not quite as bad you get with
the if you subtract the 96 from the
from the 226 you're getting pretty close
to that 100 i initially
mentioned so i
i i don't expect you to agree with me i
don't expect your vote
i i just my job is to be as clear
and transparent as i i can be on this
representative waller
well i was going to ask the same
question when i left here
last week i thought that karen had come
forth with
um a reluctant proposal
was definitely reluctant on her part but
she was trying to
uh she was trying to
be reasonable i thought and she brought
in um a hundred
a hundred positions the idea of a back
of the budget hundred positions
um we've now more this more than doubles
doubles that and you know i think that
for the last
year um the department
has really been having to to function
and we need to we need to help them
get back to where they're functioning um
in a non-crisis mode between the
pandemic and losing
a lot of employees i'm sure who needed
to be home with family
and maybe some who decided i've got to
retire i'm sure there's a whole
bunch of reasons why there is a very
large vacancy rate right now
but i think we need we need to all be
working towards helping the department
get back to
normal where they can um really
provide the kind of services that we
need in new hampshire so
i'm very disappointed to see
the the hundred i was worried about the
hundred
and i'm more than double worried about
the um
226.
yes ma'am i i don't have much to
different to say than what i just said
to
representative rogers similar concern i
i would just want to reemphasize that
given their vacancy rate as of the 11th
of march
that after imposing this paperwork
reduction because it's not a real
reduction um
and it's not a real reduction because
due to their vacancy rate
they have a a really strong number of
people that they could still add to
their payroll
before they hit this this new threshold
so so it's not crippling in the sense
that if they just
take a time out take a look at what
their priorities are
they have vacancies that they could move
around to priorities
and probably be fine and be better off
than they were this year
certainly and the pandemic will
eventually go away and so
the the crisis management will
go away and they can go back to
methodical uh planning and executing
with the higher personnel count that
they've had during the pandemic
so i i don't i don't view it as as as
bleak has been described
representative nordgren thank you very
much mr chair
um i think for the people listening in
it would be helpful to explain again and
it could be i glazed over because
i was astounded at the number but
explain again the 226 positions are
some of these people already employed at
healthcare
are these people that would have been
new hires
in their budget okay
so uh if you if you were if we were to
look
at i think that's a fair question but
i'll
i'll get to your your your the main the
main thing you're
asking i think is if
we go forward with this level
does this force the department to
terminate anyone who's been hired the
answer to that is
definitively no it would not force them
to do that they would
still have plenty of room to do that
would it force them
to forego and or make it difficult for
them to do
agreed upon step increases or to pay for
the personnel benefits
no it's all still in there and it's all
still in there
they had 507 vacancies department-wide
uh as of the 11th of march
and and so by
um and then in in
in the governor's budget was
anticipating
growing the head count to 32 26
so this 226 cut
cut would take them to 3 000
department wide well as of the 11th of
march
department-wide they had 2646 people
employed so there's 400 people
that they still need to go find in a
situation with workforce shortages
and and uh on board them and and
and then and so i think they have
room to grow this is this is not
the kind of cut that that i took several
times
in corporate america where
where you just had to cut period and
and government is protected from the
realities of the real world
because here we are in an economic
crisis
and we're debating how much we should
grow
head count and in my proposal here
they're still able to grow head count
considerably
and i think it's probably more than
they'll actually be able to
um to hire so i
i i think it'll be
tough and from a management perspective
but having to be really careful about
what they're doing
but i believe that we've hired good
enough managers that they can
that they're up to the task so
do you have a follow-on or well i just i
just wanted to maybe take
issue with the fact that we have an
economic crisis
it's my understanding that the ways and
means committee
is coming up with that came up with more
money
at the end of the week and i would just
what think that needs to be something we
discuss soon
to see what we're doing with that money
um i i think there's still a large
number of people that became unemployed
in the pandemic that have not gone back
to work
for those people were in a crisis
representative waller um yes i just
i just wanted to add one thing and that
is it hasn't been said
is um the department
as all state government has been under a
hiring freeze
um it has been lifted now but it was but
they were under hiring freeze
for probably nine to ten months
so their vacancy rate was sort of
artificially held down because they were
not able to recruit and hire during that
period
and i also want to i'm also concerned
because
i would like to know how this is going
to affect i know that
at new hampshire hospital we started the
path
program remember we moved people over to
the philbrook center
and so as a transitional housing and
then
used that when those folks were on
for children in order to start to
address some of those problems in the
emergency rooms
and i know that there had to be new
staff hired for that
so when the governor had more staff
hired in his budget probably
a part of that was because of making
that adjustment and opening up those i
think it was
20 beds um
so i would really i when i see
226 positions it really concerns me that
um we don't have all the we don't have
all the information we need
so i i think that's a fair point and and
just uh
just to uh maybe uh complete it a little
i i would point out that uh at the end
of fy 19
2916 with these
uh reductions in the governor's budget
in place
the the new authorizations would be
three thousand
which is more than two thousand nine
hundred and sixteen
and that is not even
counting the fact that we have 96
head count at sununu that can be
reprogrammed
and and given the vacancy rate takes us
well
below what was authorized at the end of
fy 19.
i think our management at dhhs
is good enough to have
these flexible resources to apply
to the most urgent priorities and i'd
agree with you
that if we were in the room with
management making management
priority decisions i would put the path
center very high
i certainly put it higher than the
sununu center
so i i it
you know we can't do their job for them
from here
but i think if we give them additional
resources over what they have
uh and say you need to prioritize how
you're going to grow
that that's that's not unreasonable
particularly
given what's happened to so many
of our brothers and sisters out in the
i'm sorry i just forgot to lower my hand
representative nordran do you have a
follow-up
yes please um i'm looking at the agenda
that we have
um that you sent out and i don't see any
place
listed where we're going to talk about
the
new money that ways and means has found
and how that fits into our overall
discussion
i don't know if representative weiler
has any comments on that
i thought we should maybe just get that
out on the table
so we know where we are with that and if
it can
maybe uh alleviate some of the concerns
we have
as we look at the pages i think that's a
it's a good topic and i think the the
next
slide that uh kevin's excuse me mr
ripple is going to put up
that that shows that high level
summaries may be a good place for
uh representative wyler if he once can
talk to us about the new and improved
ways and means ideas now
keep in mind i i think until ways and
means
gets an update past the house
technically i think we're still on the
same trajectory that we're supposed to
live within the ways and means estimates
but but i i will defer to uh
wiser souls on that issue
uh i'm so we'll so we'll talk about it
representative norgren but there's a
better better moment to do it than this
i think
um department-wide reduction with
exemption for certain direct services
areas
so the other day i think it was about a
week ago
when we went through an exercise of
reviewing medicaid reviewing chip
reviewing
um the developmentally disabled lines
uh the the the direct health care lines
uh i think uh
i think we were unanimous that
those direct care lines
were things that that that we probably
would all
support or if not all of us a majority
would support i think all of us actually
but um so so the way that hb2
is being written as i understand it is
we're going to ask for a department-wide
reduction
uh and that um but we're going to try to
exempt
direct care programs
so that we're still delivering health
care
to the most needy in our society without
restricting them so um so i'll let mr
ripple talk a little bit about
uh how that might be worded for the
certain direct service areas
um but this is a department-wide um
reduction of of 50 million
of which i understand most of it
if not all of it can come in really good
management of the higher lag as they
bring people on
and the reduced personnel lines from the
reductions above so um so mr ripple do
you want to say something there or i
just i'm inviting you to
or here's how it's currently being
drafted by
ols no reductions
shall be made to appropriations in the
following areas developmental services
including acquired brain disorder
services and children's in-home support
services
the children's health insurance program
or county programs including the state
share of funding for nursing facilities
and other
long-term care services so those areas
would all be exempted by this back
then what about the medicaid lines
that's not being exempted um at least
not in this version
because there's a lot of money in that
line
and the department spent significantly
less than their appropriation in fiscal
20. so including that in the carve out
my may hinder their ability to meet this
kevin have you calculated or have you
had the department help you calculate
how much federal money we will we we
have the potential to lose
when we're reducing the um general fund
by 50 million dollars over the biennium
since most of the most of the um
funding in the department uh
also receives federal federal money so
how much
how much are we really cutting the
budget here
i haven't calculated that and i haven't
received from hhs
the amount that would be reduced so they
had an opportunity to do that
so as a follow-up could i just ask
wouldn't it
really be a fairly good
estimate aren't most of their programs
um a 50-50 match with the federal
government
so that this 50 million really looks
more like
i don't know the 50 50 is the average
match rate but they certainly do get a
lot of
federal funds i would have to ask the
department for their
for their estimate of how much the total
thank you kevin thanks i appreciate that
so so in theory though they have uh
general funds that we invest that don't
have federal
matching money because we think it's a
good thing to invest
in so we're spending general funds
without federal
augmentation but we also have those
programs do we not
that's true there are certainly general
funded uh programs only
it really varies across the department
which is why it's difficult to give an
estimate
right and i don't think you could give a
really great estimate
until we knew what the health what the
management team prioritized if they're
given a task to reduce general funds and
they have
you know two two accounts one that gets
federal match and one that doesn't i
would think that they're
good enough managers to to pick the one
where
i guess that's a statement and not a
question so
um i guess i believe in the management
ability of the
of the the commissioner on down good
leadership
team this is an opportunity for them to
lead
yes ma'am i think that all becomes
really complex
and you'd really have to have a lot more
a lot more information because some of
the things that
um might be 100
general funds and no federal funds might
be things that
um by law we are obligated to do
by by state law we're obligated to do so
i don't know it seems like i would need
a lot more information but
i'm sure the department could give us
sort of a estimate of
how many dollars we lose every time we
cut a general fund dollar i mean i'm
sure they have
some sort of an average um
so as i understand our role relative to
theirs they've been doing this since
july and they have been operating in
this environment
for a lot of their career so when you
say that they would
that we would need to know a lot more
information than we do
i i think the managers and leaders of
dhhs already know vastly more
than our division iii committee can
never know because we're not in
the operational flow of information
uh i and again as as they set their
priorities
i would expect them to prioritize those
programs that have a statutory
requirement to them
that that would that would that would
exceed
the priority of a discretionary program
that they
chose to develop and implement on their
own so
so i i don't doubt that they have a true
they would have a tremendous challenge
of rethinking
what they wanted to do and having them
think about what they need to do
wanting and needing are two different
things
represent i'm ready to go to
representative weiler unless you have a
follow-up
oh i my own my only follow-up is that
um i i really feel like it is
and i i i'm well aware of back of the
budget
reductions i i understand how they work
and i
actually have been a part of having
budgets that
in the end had to have back of the
budget reductions but
um i don't think we've given the
department
any guidance in how we as the
legislature we're here to speak
for we're here to speak for the
legislature
how the legislature would like to see
some of these reductions made
um and i think that's our role i think
that
we should have gone through more
carefully the budget and decided that
there were things that we didn't think
um needed to be done and
given the department some guidance i
know
but i'm i'm very disappointed to see
that what you're basically
doing is just back of the budget
reductions
and we haven't given the department no
guidance as to what
it is we would like i i personally
don't have a suggestion of what how we
would find 50 million dollars
in general funds but um obviously
um other members of the committee do
yes ma'am and just to
clarify a a point where we agree
i i think i think we agree that we
should give them some guidance
and i think hb2 as we exempt certain
direct service areas
that's that's part of our guidance
and because there are set of federal and
state laws
on the books that they have to comply
with that's a lot of their guidance
right there
so so i i would i would say
while i completely agree with you that
we need to give them legislative
guidance
i i would i would just add that i think
they have a tremendous amount of
guidance to work with
representative representative weiler
thank you i think we're spending too
much time on this because we've
been doing it for years we've had back
of the budget cuts
for this agency as long as i can
remember we've done it on this agency
more than any other
because they are so big and so complex
and they overlap and so
in so many areas that we've we've
quite often done this and then they are
allowed to come back to fiscal
and they can reorganize and move things
around move dollars around move people
around
and i think a budget maybe the last
budget
we had them coming back with we gave
them a total number that they could were
allowed
and then when they had that were fun
were approved but not funded they could
move someone from
retirement or resignation or
reorganization they could move someone
from the slot that was eliminated
to a slot that was still there and that
worked we never heard any problems about
they had to stop
functioning or couldn't do some
particular thing
huge agency we've done this before and
you know
this is nothing new i wish we wouldn't
so is there any more commentary
on the section called hb1 back of the
budget sections there are two personnel
and department-wide
not seeing any uh let's talk about
some hb2 adjustments we have removed
section 37 this was
1.5 million that i think we voted on
last friday
where we just removed it and this is a
reflection of removing it this was the
program
that that had about 800 and
some odd potential uh
applicants and no procedures for who to
make eligible so um so we
we dropped that is there any comment on
that
remove section 38
[Music]
we did vote on this we took the 200 000
out of of hb2 because
uh this seemed to be the opposite of the
mmis
that this was really ongoing operations
that should have been in the operating
budget
so we removed it from hb2 because it
didn't seem to belong there
and as we talked about it and moved it
that's when we found out that it would
also
provide a six hundred thousand dollar
federal match
um so are there any comments or
i'm not seeing any that add the mmis
contract costs this is the
inverse of what we talked about up in
okay i don't know so we've discussed
that
so the one-time sununu youth center
money
uh to help them close down
is that 2.65 million uh we discussed
that when we were talking about the hb1
appropriations but
is there any more comment on that
representative
wallner
i just wondered are we have we're not
doing we're not carrying
any money into the into 23.
we we just think we
or is the 2.65
is it not is that la non-lapsing
uh representative weiler you've had lead
on this area what
could would you respond yeah it wouldn't
it wouldn't last till the end of the
biennium
so if if the program slides into 2023
the money's still available
i'm not so concerned i mean the program
would prob would end but i'm consider
concerned about um
just things like mothballing the
building
the training of staff all those kinds of
things
that we wouldn't necessarily be able to
have all of that really completed by
june 30th
so i want to just be sure that they can
carry that money over into the next
next year to use that for for that
well perhaps we could footnote that
particular one so
to make sure that that happens okay
thank you
so so mr ripple would you would you take
a note
to just make sure that that 2.65 million
in
2022 is non-lapsing so it can be
invested through the 23 fiscal year
i will and i believe that those
appropriate there are four separate
appropriations in the house
bill 2 language for sununu center
transition costs totaling the 2.65 and i
believe they're all for the
for the total buying for the whole
biennium
okay so reducing funding in section 35
by
removing alvarez and marcel dd
redesign costs if you remember
there they we looked at five line items
and i i think there was a unanimous
belief that lines one through four made
sense because we had
little investment and great savings
pretty quickly
and then where where we got hung up
and unable to move forward was uh
on what to do with the dd line item
and i think uh representatives rogers
and earth talked
uh a couple three times this weekend and
and apparently were unable to
to reach a resolution so so this
reduced funding is the payback
from the investments i think it's the
net of the investments
uh with the paybacks involved
for lines one through four so so
can we clarify that uh first mr ripple
that this is just one through four
sorry the cost of the first four items
for the table that the department put
together last week
was 3.3 million dollars so the
amendment will contain an appropriation
of 3.3 million dollars so this is
roughly 6.7 million less than
is the net the 6 million minus the 3
million in investment for a 3 million
net
no this what you say the savings shown
here of 6.7 million
from the original 10 million 43 000
appropriation
down to the new 3.3 million dollar
program
okay so where did oh it's down below
excuse me
i just said okay i got it
so so this line is we're removing
line five we're not investing in line
fives
this shows the removal of line five
correct and then the net is shown in the
other
those are four million and six point two
million because those are the savings we
expect to receive
from the monies that we're investing in
lines one through four
that's right all right thank you so
so hopefully everyone understands what
those two lines how they work together
representative wallner
yes i i'm really concerned that we
taken out from this proposal
the the dd redesign um
the 38 people we haven't really left the
department anything we took
off to keep working on
um the redesign for the dd
and what i what the part of it that
really concerns me is learning that
there are 38
people that developmentally disabled
folks
that we are providing services for
and paying for services in florida
my understanding is from the department
that those services are costing between
and 500 000 per person
um and besides it costing a lot
the downside to me is that they're away
from their families
and it seems like we need to be moving
towards
getting those folks back to new
hampshire where they
have family and have a support system
[Music]
this just seemed this seems like a
very poor decision
to to not provide any funding to move
forward with a plan to try to bring
those folks back i think it would
probably
seems to me it would probably have um
been the largest savings in the end over
the next several years
and if we don't have some sort of a
network here in new hampshire for those
folks
there may be more people that we're
sending out of state and very expensive
placements
so i'm very disappointed that we did not
go forward
with some funding in that line to allow
the department to continue the planning
for trying to build a system that can
care for people here in new hampshire
and not sending them out of state
so that's all i have to say
that's that's that's that's uh that's a
that's a good
summary of your view point thank you i
from my
my viewpoint what has happened here is
that
the the a m report came very late in the
process
the department had it two weeks before
they shared it with us
when the a m people came in here they
gave us uh
you know a decent summary and and in our
testimony we were able to get some
anecdotal data points
about the impact of the program
um but what we have not gotten is we
haven't gotten
sort of a comprehensive project view
where we've had a chance to challenge
some of the assumptions like for example
uh in it's my understanding that all
the group homes that we have developed
organically within the community
and that the state funding is just a
small piece of the total amount of
revenue they need to operate the group
homes
they rely on a tremendous amount of
charitable work that comes from the
community that has embraced them and
built them
and grew them and that rather than using
that
tried and true method of kind of organic
development of group homes this
is a proposal to do a top-down driven
set of projects and if and if those fail
because they don't have the community
charitable support
then the estimates of how much the state
would need to invest
are understated and then if we
end up paying more fully for those new
four group homes then what's going to
happen is the other 12 or so group homes
in the state i forget the exact number
maybe it's nine
but those that have been relying heavily
on charitable donations they'll go this
isn't fair
those four people are getting more state
money than we are we need our state
money too
and so there's actually a potential
hidden bill here that nobody is seeing
and looking at
because we haven't evaluated this as a
total program
this this feels like a really good thing
to do
for all of the reasons you just
mentioned but
it's not right i don't think from an
investment decision
and so i would encourage the department
to really work
on putting this together in a more
programmatic view and
taking it to the senate where the senate
at the beginning of their process can
become begin to evaluate this
rather than what happened to us where we
weren't allowed to even look at it until
we were almost done
and so i don't think it was fair to us
to be put in the position to have to
make a multi-million dollar decision
affecting all of these people and then
have it look like we don't care
because they didn't give us the time and
the program documents that we should
have had
so i think
that if the department thinks this is a
good idea
and it sounds like it is that they have
an opportunity
to go work it out with the senate in a
comprehensive
programmatic view that looks at the
long-term risks
associated with the project we didn't
have the opportunity to do that
so your hand your hand is up i apologize
for
uh is there any further question on this
all right seeing none um
there there there will be a discussion
to
this afternoon on section 34 the
financial implications of that that we
have not talked about this morning that
will end up going into this
tomorrow's version but i know
representative rogers has
some input in that and i've known for a
longer time that mister
or excuse me representative earth does
as well so
so there's this is not complete but it's
pretty pretty darn complete
uh next next slide please
okay all right
so do you want to walk us through this
sure this one is pretty simple it's
simply the governor's
uh recommended appropriation totals in
house bill 1
compared with the proposal that you just
saw
so actually i'll go back to the other
document
quickly because of these four
items the only ones that you'll see
in the house build one totals for hhs
are
these right here showing 9.9 million
reduction in fiscal 22 and a 10.8
million reductions fiscal 23.
so if we then go back over here you'll
see that general fund reduction
in 22 and that general fund reduction in
and there's an associated loss of
federal funds here which is mainly
related to
the removal of mmis and the movement of
that appropriation to house bill 2. so
as you can see from the note here
federal funds are dropping by 32.9
million and 22 and 34.8 million
in 23 but those federal funds will be
authorized by the house bill to
appropriation
so so am i right to hear you say that it
while it looks like a loss on this
in reality it's not a loss because the
fiscal committee
uh given that this is an hb2 can approve
and receive those
that same amount of federal funds later
that's true and actually the way the
house bill 2 and i
the way the house bill 2 language is
being drafted the department wouldn't
even need to go to fiscal to accept
so this this is just a sheet that
doesn't reflect reality but it's the
sheet that reflects
the format and methodology we use at
this stage
right representative walner
yes kevin could you tie back
the first page the total additions
reductions to the budget as introduced
okay to this
to this page that we are
looking at sure the only thing
so you'll see here the general fund
reduction in 22 of 9.9 million
yes that is the same as
this figure right here so the second
page really only relates to
the first part of this page the hb1
appropriations section
got it got it so it doesn't relate to
the back of the budget
reductions correct because those won't
be reflected in the appropriations
totals
okay so this is this this uh
page that we're looking at here is sort
of artificially low
because it isn't the full picture the
the reductions are artificially low yes
thank you
thank you it really isn't a very helpful
piece
um you need to look at the whole picture
not just not just
so the other piece that we could talk
about here if you're
if you're ready to uh representative
weiler
we already knew that the governor's
budget was based on
an fy 22
77 or something 77 no it was the
biennium
the biennium uh the governor's budget
was 77 million higher than
ways and means ways and means has now
come back
and informally said that they think
it could actually end up being higher
now we've not voted on that as a house
so we're still on the trajectory
from last ways and means but but just so
that we can anticipate and plan
what what can you tell us about
um discussing it with some of the other
divisions
this money that has been added
there's places where they took away
money that was expected to go
municipalities they took away revenue
sharing they took away state aid grants
and they took away the increase in the
meals and rooms tax
delivery to the towns of cities so
it would seem like there were more
reductions in those areas than there
were
in what the governor sent us on hhs i
anticipated
he'd have more reductions in hhs because
of the huge growth it had in 21
but he didn't most of his reductions
were in other areas so if
if more funds are available it seems
like that's where they should be
put and also there's there's uh
several people that want a speed up on
the
tax cuts but looking at head discussions
with the
ways and means and where some people
wanted the
interest and dividends tax to go away in
two years rather than five
but that would have taken 170 or 180
million
to do that and we didn't have that much
more money
and money that we did have would seem to
be more appropriate going to the towns
and cities and the programs that had
been suspended
because that some of those towns had
come to to uh
rely on that money especially if you're
building a water treatment plant a
sewage treatment plant and you're
expecting some state aid grants and some
other distributions like that and all of
a sudden boom they're gone
uh that's more of a shock than anything
that happened in hhs
and if you're anticipating a better
distribution of meals and rooms tax to
go into your town budget
and boom that's gone that would seem
like that was a hole that had more
priority
than putting more money back in hhs
especially when they already are at a
point where they can't grow to the money
that was given them
so that would be a more help to more
people
that was that was the way we tentatively
decided we haven't worked it all out yet
thank you representative waller you have
a question
yes my question is for uh chairman
weiler
um so i think on friday you told us
it was an additional 127 million is that
is that about right okay
and you're saying it's
it looks like you're looking at putting
it into revenue sharing
and the rooms and meals tax it goes back
to communities is that correct
that's correct and is that the whole
i mean you're going to put the whole 127
million
into those two programs those are just
some of the ones we discussed
we haven't uh discussed much with
division two
what they thought as a need because they
haven't had a chance to talk to karen
but lynn and i and jess were talking
about some of these other things
and that's where we felt the need that
we had seen cuts
um that people on money people were
expecting
so better talk with karen about what she
might see in hp2 but she hasn't done
much in the way of cutting in hp2 there
might be more money going into education
and we'll have to talk about that
okay that was my actually that's what
was
going through my heads are you not i
mean are we
not seeing any of this 127 million
dollars going into education which goes
directly to our communities
i think i think there will be but at
this point we haven't
looked at all the figures and i've got
to get together i haven't had the time
to get together with the other divisions
and say okay if you had more money where
would it go but
uh karen and i haven't had a chance to
meet but i haven't met with flynn
and those were her big things that you
know here's his programs that people
were anticipating boom were taken away
from them so you gotta
pay attention to those and i haven't
talked with karen about any programs she
had that
that might have happened and i think
some of that would be an education on
her
budget so just one follow-up so
for division one and division two you
anticipate them
having at least some part of 127 million
dollars
to use for to
avoid i guess avoid uh reductions in
their
their budgets but none of that 127
million is coming to health and human
services
if we collectively decide that
we need more in a certain area then
certainly that will be in the
thank you so i have a couple questions
for you sir
i want to understand 127 million number
is is that 127 million
on in addition to what ways and means
had been projecting
and if so then they had a 77 million
dollar hole to begin with relative
to the governor does this now just put
us 50 million ahead of the governor's
budget
that's that's what i'm thinking but i
haven't had that clearly explained
by uh ways and means but that's my
impression that it only gives you
an additional 50. thank you sir and then
the
second question would be um i
it's not in our division but i had heard
that there were
some critical water and sewage
investments that are also direct public
health investments
that isn't in our budget but as a
as a public health advocate i i would
want these sewage and water
projects to compete favorably
i think we can all agree on that
do you have any clue how much that is
those would be
in i i don't want to that one
um no i didn't look at the cut my
recollection is from previous budgets
these run around
30 million a year something in that area
all right thank you sir uh
representative norgren you had your hand
up and then representative wallner
yes mr chair i'm a little worried that
we don't know a whole lot more from
representative weiler
about what money might come to division
three
when it appears that um you're planning
to vote on the budget today
in division three so it seems like we've
got a chicken and an egg
situation i was wondering
how we can somehow get some
more clear direction from the chair
about
what money we might have for division
three
that that's that's a good follow-up let
me
let me say what i think is true
and then representative weiler please be
prepared to correct me
uh i i think what uh
what we are supposed to do per
whether it's statute or just the rules
of how we do the budget
is that the budget that we pass as a
finance committee
and send to the house for a vote must be
predicated
on the ways and means revenue number
that we received
a month or two ago when we were in
session
and that uh we're we're not allowed at
this point
to do anything with the enhanced
revenues
because it hasn't been passed by the
house
and so it's not a chicken or egg thing
it's a sequential thing
it starts with the ways and means
revenue estimate
then we spend it and then
we take our our budget to
the house and when we're at the house
ways and means may come back and say
oh we have another vote to take on
higher revenues
and that we would take that vote and
and and at that point we have a budget
that's below
the new ways and means estimate but but
that's the official process as i
what we might do is pass the budget that
complies
with the revenue estimates adopted by
the house because that's what we're
required to do
and at the same time we could have
contingency things
so that if at the point they
pass in this next sessions we'll have
if they pass things that are um
reflective of this extra 50 some million
then at that point
we can we can come forward and say okay
now that the money has been accepted by
the
by the uh full body then here are the
contingency things that we'd like to add
and we'll have those ready to go forward
as an amendment so
that's what i foresee as happening but
until we have
an official uh appreciation by the house
of the new
new revenue i don't think we can do
anything but try to
to meet that first estimate we were
given
representative
so uh chairman weiler
for are we doing this on wednesday the
seventh is that
is the budget on the floor on wednesday
i think i had a schedule for the sixth
the budget's on the floor of the house
on the sixth okay right i i think the
six was the budget briefing but the
house
you're correct that i'm gonna brief the
budget on the six we'll all we'll i'll
be there all the divisions briefing the
budget on the sixth
and then we probably will vote on the
seventh but there's the three days there
i don't know when the
uh speaker will have it it may go
by you know alphabetically by committee
so we may get to it maybe get to it on
the eighth
okay so if we're doing the briefing on
the sixth
are we doing that we're doing that in
bedford at the sports plaza
right yes yeah on the sixth
okay so the soonest we could have the
budget on the floor would be
the eighth is that correct because you
have to have two days
i think that's what the rules say i'm
trying to remember that one
explosion that sounds familiar with what
got said in this division earlier
i mean i haven't thought about i've
never thought about it for two years so
just it seems like you had to do it two
days before you could vote on the budget
but thank you for that recollection
you're looking
you're in charge now you look it up i i
just trying to remember
um okay so that would be the eighth
so you're thinking that on like
maybe the seventh or
the morning of early morning of the
eighth or something like that
we would hear ways and means bring in
this these new revenue
estimates that's your thought and then
we would add to the budget you're
thanks for your help i'm going to gel in
my mind a little better yes
i'm not here to help no
no well it's been it's been a while
since i was chair of finance it's been
more recent
but yes i think that that'll be the way
it'll work thanks for those hints
so does that mean we need to recommend
to the speaker that he special order
the ways and means estimate to the first
order of business on the 7th
which sure makes sense or early on the
8th
well if we have it on the seventh we
just have more time to think
and and and because then we have to
prepare our own amendment based on that
don't we i mean so we need ols
yes well i think we can almost
anticipate it being accepted
we can almost anticipate what we would
like to do
with the extra money so we'll have those
prepared
your hand is still up representative
well i guess i would just mention that
um a lot of people
have made have been told that they're
going to be in the sports arena on the
7th 8th and 9th
and now we're adding the 6th and
um i really think that
that that kind of thing needs to be we
need to let
all of our colleagues in the house know
what's going to be expected
of them so thank you
hopefully we'll get it i'll stop helping
i'll stop helping
all right are there any other comments
or questions
uh let's go back mr ripple to the image
of the work plan for the day that was in
that email
you know what i'm referring to
it's 11 12 i think we've got another
hour let's see how we're going to invest
it
i think we can talk about um
review of the veterans home and plan can
you can you just
show that and uh and by the hand plan
what i meant by that
was
just what we think we want to do with
the veterans zone
because we've been talking about the
department of health and human services
so much
can you bring up the just the bottom
line of the veterans home the budget
view
sure
so i'm referring to the bottom line
okay so um we've we've seen this we've
been briefed on it
uh the commandant went through the
details
it is true isn't it mr ripple that that
personnel reduction
does not affect this line item
that's correct so what
what you see is what you get relative to
uh what uh i understand
you don't have any amendments on this do
you from anyone
i don't i i had never sensed any
willingness or desire on the part of
anyone to
increase or decrease this part of the
budget
um and i had asked for you know feedback
uh last week and didn't get any on this
except i may have seen something that
suggested
um that the that the blue team
is in favor of supporting the veterans
home governor's
proposal so
do we need a motion or
i i i would like to get us past this
point in saying
i you know i'm prepared to accept the
governor's budget here
i think you could make a motion to
accept the governor's proposed budget
for the veterans home and that would be
sufficient
representative i would move that we
accept the governor's budget
we're having a hard time hearing you is
there a second
the seconded by representative wyler
i'm not seeing anyone's hands raised
so um i think we're ready to call a roll
a motion to accept uh what's what would
i use for the number on this
is this an au kevin
there are multiple accounting units i
think it's sufficient to just say
the proposed budget for the veterans
home and that'll encompass everything
thank you all right so that's the motion
to accept
the governor's budget for the veterans
home
uh motion in a second and
call the roll on how you vote
representative earth
yes representative weiler votes yes
representative bean
yes representative walnut
yes representative nordgren
yes representative rogers
yes representative edwards
yes he's the chairman of the voter 7-0
thank you um all right with that
done we can move on to where it says uh
our topic was going to be hb2
section 35 a m but because
of the discussion that we had
during the line item review i
i believe that we've completed this task
is there anyone that wants to have a
second bite at the apple of talking
about where we ended up with the
not seeing any uh that would take us to
discussion of the sysc
hb2s and uh i think earlier we discussed
that there's going to be nine amendments
that we may be able to review today and
that will do it this afternoon
so so i propose that we uh
we defer that conversation until we can
just have the conversation based on
actual amendments
is there any disagreement anyone want to
talk
i'm not seeing any and then on the
april 12th meeting this was for
uh the section of hb2 that we removed
from hb2 on an earlier vote and that we
want to
uh have a meeting on the 12th of april
to get more information
i've drafted a potential amendment
gotten some feedback on it
and i just wanted to make sure that
folks understood
that i'm actively waiting for you to
submit
language to me to add to it or to
replace
lines so i'm in a weight mode
for input also i wanted to make it
clear that similar to what we did on the
16th of march where we had an afternoon
that we invited people in
this this is kind of that same thing
so like if representative rogers wanted
to invite
the water and sewer people from concord
to come in
i'd love to hear from them um or
or anybody wanted to bring anyone in to
talk about this like
is 25 the right number for beds or 60
the right number for beds who would we
invite to have that conversation with
representative walter your hand is up
yeah i mean you said something about if
we wanted to add language or subtract
language
um i i
really wouldn't i mean this is basically
an
information session for us to get
information
and until i i mean i would really like
to hear from people before i start
um doing any other kind of um
amendment to to the language that you
put out there
i'm not even sure how we will use that
language
that's a very reasonable position and no
and that and you just gave me feedback
so so thank you you were unintentionally
helpful
oh darn and and
but representative rogers specifically
called out a couple
areas that she wanted a tighter rewrite
and so i'm i'm i'm kind of hoping she'll
just send me some language and i'll cut
and paste it
and that's that's me just trying to get
ready
before the meeting it's not to
foreshadow or predetermine the results
but but that's kind of my way of getting
um representative rogers you think you
might send me a couple of sentences
um what i'm going to do is ask the mayor
to look at it and
ask the city to give me what language
they'd be comfortable with
yes ma'am good idea great approach
all right so are there any other
questions about
what we're trying yes sir uh mr uh i
don't know why i keep calling him
representative weiler um
we probably want to hear from the uh
corrections as well as the hhs
of behavioral health and how they would
adapt to all this because it's
it's i'm not sure what percentage of the
secure psychiatric unit would be moved
from the
corrections department over to mental
health some of them will still remain
but
it may affect their uh their staffing
and so on
we want to hear about that yes sir since
those are state
agencies um mr ripple can you extend
those invitations to them
and what i'm looking for for the
committee is the kind of the
non-traditional
non-state players
okay so this afternoon is
is a busy day still by itself
so uh we'll start at 2 30
uh and i uh anticipate going into recess
here in
just a minute until 2 30. uh
representative wallner
you're handling yes i'm sorry i missed
the timing on
on the 12th are we doing that in the
afternoon or the morning
i believe it's on it's ready to go to
the calendar what did we do for the
calendar 9
i don't remember okay so we'll we'll
find out over lunch
okay i i think i'm like 90 sure it went
if there's any way it could be afternoon
i would appreciate that but
well the reason i'm so sure that it was
in the at 9 30 is because i recall mr
ripple saying that in the long
long-range calendar
he's asked to be in the senate in the
afternoon that oh
okay that's what we're doing that's fine
we need mr ripple for sure i think so
uh representative nordgren and then
representative weiler
yes thank you um could we have a
clarification
from um chairweiler
i think the question came up that if we
were executing as a full
committee on friday it wasn't in the
calendar so is it going to be in the new
calendar
or yes we when
when we make sure that division two
division one of finished i think
division one has assured me i'm still up
to get to hold the karen
and uh i would be able to get it in
uh wednesday and it would still that
calendar would begin with friday
so it would be in a calendar that would
come out thursday
and one of the things uh for the
afternoon's
schedule both representative irf and i
are expected to be at a county and state
finance committee meeting
uh at from one and they're showing at
one to two
one to two thirty this afternoon
so um
either one or both of us might be absent
for part of that time
no sir we're going to go into recess and
not come back until
2 30. and we we're doing that so that
you and representative earth can go to
your meeting and not miss anything
all right thank you so oh it appears to
represent
representative weiler um yes
is it is it a firm date that we're going
to be
at the sports arena on the 6th or
i mean i think that's something as as
representative waller said we need to be
circulating
among the membership of the house so i'm
just wondering
if that's been reserved for us or what
that was my latest conversation with the
uh speaker and the chief of staff i'll
make sure that that's
ending up in the calendar i'll be seeing
them uh
later this week okay maybe you can let
us know
after you have that conversation okay
thank you are there any other
uh questions um okay
is there any any so we'll we'll go into
recess uh
with the idea that we'll come back at 2
30 representative weiler
if you if you could sir i i want to give
you a call i just need to
check some notes with you sir um okay
i'll call you on your cell phone here
shortly all right
i got a call here i got to answer now so
yeah give it give it 10 minutes
yes sir uh okay so if you'll stop the
recording and put us on recess until 2
30.
let's start recording
uh we're now recording and uh we're
coming back
division three from uh this morning uh
this
we've recessed and uh uh
we're gonna let's take a look at the
things we're gonna do this afternoon
you can scroll down we did complete the
morning
agenda so this afternoon we're going to
start by talking about 254
in section 26 section 34.
there's actually kind of two parts to
that hb there's uh
the hb amendments that have been uh
offered and then there's also
a discussion of the family planning hb1
uh budget area that we'll we'll talk
about both representative irf and
representative rogers
uh have have some prepared thoughts i'm
i'm not sure what we'll see but
but we they they can certainly speak and
show what they they've got
uh and then we'll discuss them to see if
there's any natural overlap
and and decide what to do hb
2 um is just is that
hb2 available the mmis moving into hb2
that amendment ready yes
that would be it's a house bill one
amendment but yes that one is ready
okay and then the hb2 of
the back of the budget the the 50
million
biennium cut is that that's also
it's also an hb one i haven't gotten
that one back yet
okay so maybe you'll get it by then but
if we don't have them both uh on so that
we can kind of look at them
really kind of together um i i think uh
we'll we'll end up pushing those till
tomorrow i think it's uh
unavoidable for us to get together at
uh get together tomorrow uh
at 2 p.m but but we'll see
and then uh it's not on what mr ripple
is showing
but um over lunch
uh we got a request to
consider a cfi footnote
that nobody has seen yet other than
representative wallner myself
i think representative irf may have had
a chance to glance at it
we'll talk about that and then we'll
we'll see where we're at
are there any questions about what we're
not seeing any would you bring up
the hb2 on 254
share it the so by that
which document i mean the hb2 where
we took um the incarceration standards
of 254 and we put it into an hb2
language
well you haven't yet put that in and i
don't believe there's
i don't think i've gotten that amendment
back yet
i think that's one of the ones i'm
hitting on that that happened
if i've not given you and i've i've
miscommunicated and dropped the ball
but um but the idea was
um and then it's still subject for the
committee to discuss
but the but the idea was that we would
take the meat
of the h hp 254
new incarceration standards put them
into
hb2 language consider it in
hb2 as an ad and then
then the possibility remain that we
would
vote to retain h.b 254
in case we needed to do more work on it
over the fall
okay right and that is the text of house
bill 254
is one of the amendments that i sent to
ols as part of the sununu center package
but it's one of the ones that i haven't
gone back
okay so um okay good
um so let's skip over that because i
don't think we can
go into 254 without that hb to
uh to discuss um hp
section 26 do you do you have that
sheet where we're showing progress on
can i offer an update yes sir
go ahead all right discussions over the
break
with the uh leadership
and dates so now they don't want me to
do the final exact session this friday
they wanted to be in the calendar for
four days so they want my
final our final exact session to be on
the 30th next tuesday
um so that's next week
and then so the 30th for the exact
session
then on the for the
joint commission or for the the
briefing to the house that will be on
the fifth because as
representative walnut pointed out to us
you have to have two days from the time
you brief the
budget until we vote on it so we will
brief it on the fifth uh that will be
probably a
zoom meeting not a meeting in the uh
athletic center so on the fifth it won't
be a meeting in the athletic center
or the six it won't be a meeting in the
athletic center it will be a zoom
session
some of us will be sitting in the house
chamber and doing a briefing from there
to
the rest of the legislature that chooses
to zoom
and as i pointed out to them we are
restricted at this point by law i would
say
that we cannot come out with a budget
that is higher than
the uh the original estimates we were
assigned
by the house ways and means even though
they've given us a recent update
but what we'll probably do we'll give a
we'll give a briefing based upon
the budget that we have to do by law
and then we'll go in on the seventh the
first thing will probably be a new
estimate
and then i think we will be ready got
enough days to work on this
to have a contingency plan okay there's
a budget we gave you now we have an
extra i think 50 million
here's the plan to spend it and so we
would bring that up then
after they have updated the uh the
income
the revenue so i think that's the only
way we can do it i think that's what i
explained to leadership
so we'll present one budget and we'll do
a contingency budget on the seventh
okay uh thanks representative rogers
representative rogers raise your hand um
representative wyler
which budget will be presented in the
calendar and given to people then
the one that we're going to give them
first that's according to law or the
real budget
the one according to law so when will
they see the real budget
that day on the floor or well i i can't
think of any other way because
here's here's here's the numbers you
were given here's the numbers you've got
to produce a budget to
brief on the budget until we have an
update
officially accepted by the legislature
there's nothing we can do to present
um an additional spending
uh plan until we have the additional
revenue
accepted and presented presented and
accepted
so but knowing that i think i will ask
the lba when they print up the document
that will go out
on the screen that here's the rumor
if it happens here's the contingency
that will be added in
so they should probably get it ahead of
time then because i was just thinking
okay what do you think of that that
would work better because i think
otherwise people are going to be so
confused that yeah
why do why do you brief us on this
budget then you're talking at the
seventh about
the budget so yeah i could think of
doing it and put language in there
to that effect okay thank you by law
what i'm require what we are required to
present
but we expect to hear this because we've
been lifted
a few days in advance by ways and means
if that is presented accepted then
it'll be the new numbers and i'll try to
explain that in that handout thank you
very much
thank you for all you people that have
had experience with this in that past
uh representative nordgren i think would
like to ask you a question sir
thank you thank you mr chair both chairs
um so i i think in
discussions i've had with other people
i've wondered
if the fact that
those numbers have to be presented
before we can present our budget
is that in an rsa or is that
in house rules or where do we see that
document
that that's what we have to do the
process is the process
written someplace or any document when
we can see tell you the truth it's what
i remembered from the dozen budgets you
and i have seen
i don't remember going back into the
laws and reading it it's just what i
recall from
all the past budgets that this is the
number you gotta you've got a budget to
and you know and in all those cases i
don't think we ever had a revised
figure that we could work from so
but but we don't know if it's
a a rule that the
house has established or that it's an
rrsa
when i start working on the handout
that'll go out on the fifth i will
research it and reference the rsas or
the rules whichever
one i come up with thank you so it will
be published so we'll all see it
thank
all you uh any further discussion around
that
um and and i think i also heard you say
that there will probably be a a
special order to have the ways and means
update the
revenue numbers like the first day of
the for the first moment of the first
day
correct and probably right
that we can go forward with what we
would have warned them on the fifth
may happen if that all comes to bear
we should in theory be ready for some
floor amendments that might be
so um did you have another question
representative norgren yes thank you um
obviously
um the democrats will be briefing our
caucus
on the budget so i assume the
republicans will be briefing
their caucus on the budget so we can
blame to each caucus the process is that
what you anticipate yeah i hope i hope
we all can explain the same
process and that uh everybody will see
it in the handout on the fifth and the
briefing on the fifth
and you know and then i'll also have it
as i said that
you and i remember there's always a
handout that goes out to people and
we'll be showing it on the screen and
maybe putting it up
on a website that here's what we plan to
do
here's what we have to do here's what we
plan to do we expect to
see a revised revenue so
hopefully like you say make sure
everybody sees it and has it written
down
and we don't don't say what the hell are
you people doing
sorry hopefully it'll all work out if
you've got any more ideas of
what i can do to make sure everybody
knows what the
process is let me know okay thanks a lot
thank you okay i'm not seeing any other
questions
so i think we can uh start with the
agenda for the afternoon which is um
we okay we just skipped over 254 but can
you bring up
hb2 section 26 so we can see it
did you want to start with that or did
you want to start with the document
showing the
status of house bill 2 sections the
second thing you just said
okay
this is one of the last hb2s that we
have to discuss
we have an amendment now to look at
don't we
you do and it would simply
actually hold on one second i think i
brought up the wrong one
but yes you do have an amendment and i
notice white space on section 35
and i don't have any notes on that so
that is the appropriation for the
alvarez and mars
recommendations we have an amendment
ready for that too let me just pull up
section 26 here
you think we're going to be able to talk
about the amendment to section 35 this
afternoon if so i'll add it to my notes
so this in the governor's recommended
trailer bill
hhs's special transfer authority would
have been extended until
july first 2023 and this would extend it
instead to the end of the biennium
in the section 26 that that was
introduced
had uh january 1 2023
right yes yes okay and
which which member sponsored this
amendment
can we scroll up a little there he is
okay so um
so just to tell you all my name is on
there because of protocol
i i actually don't support this
amendment i i don't know why
we would replace our judgment with the
governors the governor
office made a very specific decision
that january 1
2023 was uh
the right date and uh instead of
listening to the governor who is the
chief executive for
were listening to the department and i i
don't know
there's a chain of command and that i i
would tend to respect
so but but um i i
got the sense from the committee that
this is what you want and so um
so if there's an amendment to or
a motion to accept this um
amendment we we can go ahead and discuss
it and vote it out
don't move for a second
second
motion and a second to adopt this
um and okay so just to complete the
thought i'm i'm going to vote against
this
but i want everyone to just vote the way
they want to vote because it's your vote
nope not seeing any mr clerk would you
all right see the amendment number is
to hb2 which adopts
if you're in favor you'll say yes if
you're opposed you'd say no
representative earth
yes representative weiler votes yes
uh i vote no okay
representative walner yes
representative yes
representative rogers yes
representative edwards you know
mr chairman of the voters five to two
all right
thank you okay
so next up is uh
hb2 section 34 um
and there's uh there's uh
two two amendments to section 34 that
we're going to discuss
and before we discuss that i i do want
to
um talk about uh all of the email that
we received and
i i don't know i received a lot of email
i suppose
the rest of us have as well
and you know i i think the email that we
received
by and large is uh consistent with the
whole
idea of being transparent uh and open to
the public
i mean the fact that we got so much
email would suggest
there was some level of transparency um
but there was one email i in particular
i wanted to
read to the committee and to talk to the
public about for just a moment
um because in the last couple of years
um
uh this is our society and our politics
have been increasingly coarsened
and uh and we are acting less and less
as civilized as we should so this one
email i won't read who sent it
um writes i and 60 of new hampshire
residents
oppose your anti-abortion gag rule you
had to resort to dirty tricks
because for every woman you stand in
front of house
reps i can bring in a hundred and that's
no joke
i will get your names and addresses and
i will mobilize these women to protest
outside of your homes if need be
these will be peaceful protests but
relentless
your lack of integrity is appalling and
you should be ashamed
and i think that's the end of the email
and i think
um the united states and new hampshire
uh is a nation in a state where the rule
of law
matters and we have
behaved as volunteer legislators
in accordance with that rule of law
there was a bill introduced
there was a valid amendment
offered we
heard the amendment we took testimony
we've received
email we've thought about it
our role is to
receive the amendment and do what we've
done listen to testimony
discuss it vote on it
the resorting to what
comes very close to an anarchist threat
violating the sense of security of our
families
is too far and i would ask the person
who wrote that
or anyone who'd be tempted to write like
that to remember that we do this as
volunteers because we have a sense of
civic duty
and civic pride and that sort of threat
is just wholly inappropriate to our
process
and that's what i have to say about that
so um mr ripple if you could
bring up the original section 34 and
then
be prepared to bring up the leon
amendment and then
okay so i'm sure everyone's had a chance
to look at this but
i did i just did want to call
recall have everyone recall that the
original
section 34
[Music]
requires us to comply with title 19 of
the social security act
and with that let's look at
okay so it's all too big to fit onto one
page but
i i think uh i think we've all read it
um oh there we go all right
so we received a tremendous amount of
feedback on this
um the there was
a lot of reference to opposing a gag
rule um i i don't know if that's a
pejorative or
a historically accurate term but but
it's been referred to as a gag rule
and then there was a testimony from the
hospital association that
put a burden on hospitals that provide
abortions
so um i think
history the gag rule expression came up
in the 1830s
when congress prohibited itself from
history indicated that the gag rule was
not a good thing
okay so this is an amendment
that um i think represents
the essence of what the leon amendment
wanted to do i think the key
element of this is that
family planning programs that receive
family planning money from the state
be physically and financially segregated
from reproductive health facilities
and that term loosely is defined in
statute to
what is the equivalent of a
free-standing independent
abortion clinic so um
so this is requesting that um
anyone providing family planning would
be physically segregated from abortion
providers
uh it deletes
restrictions on counseling and
involved in this legislation so
um i think this is a better amendment
whether or not it's sufficient uh i i
think
i think maybe what we ought to do for a
few minutes is to try to talk about
these two things
and uh and get a sense of uh where
people are at in terms of
um these these two choices
representative rogers
thank you mr chairman um first of all um
i think we all got the emails that you
talked about and it was no one that i
had ever heard of before
and um i think that um from someone that
gets these kind of emails quite often
um i too am alarmed by getting emails
like that and so i appreciate what you
said
um and i do appreciate you attempting to
um
come up with a compromise amendment here
however
the physical separation is something
that's quite impossible to comply with
by a number of the health centers we're
talking about
these health centers are not um in any
way
um rich i guess is the first word that
comes to my mind
they're not not blessed with a large
amount of money they live day to day
quite often
the money federal monies that they've
had to do without in the past couple of
years
has been quite difficult for them one of
the amendments you'll see later that i'm
bringing in talks about that funding and
how to deal with it when we force the
health centers to
um to basically redesign their buildings
maybe even build separate buildings
so they can offer people the ability to
obtain an abortion
um and i understand that some people
don't want to have that that ability
there that's understood
people have disagreements but by this
amendment what you're doing is
is forcing these facilities to um
either stop accepting any kind of money
for the other services they do which is
providing
health care to a larger number of people
of state
or to stop offering abortions which is
something that a lot of people
do need to have in the state for
whatever reason that may be
you're making it basically totally
impossible for them to comply with this
and you're forcing them to redesign
their entire health center
and i've got to remind you that these
health centers
provide services to the state that are
that are very important
in fact in during the pandemic time in
the in the
fiscal year fiscal year 2020
97 of the chlamydia and gonorrhea
testing
in the program that health and human
services offered was completed by these
providers
and i know you served on health and
human services before coming to finance
so you're well aware that those two
diseases and stds in general
are in an epidemic proportion in the
state
the patients also cancer screening
89 of pap tests sixty-seven percent of
breast exams
are done by these providers our
low-income women
um go to these providers for their
health care
they don't have other places to go so by
forcing
all of these centers to make a decision
basically what you're doing is telling
them that
either abortions will not be available
in the state
or that they have to stop serving the
clientele that they serve
and that's really an impossible decision
it's a sophie's choice
where many of our legislators are what
you would call
pro-life or anti-choice and many of us
are what you would call pro-choice or
they would say anti-life
there's a split down the middle on this
and i don't think the finance
committee should be in a position of
saying whether the legislature is
either anti-choice or anti-life or
whatever label we want to put on it
the language that's been in here for a
number of years is probably equally
uncomfortable for both sides
but it's a compromise that's been
reached and we've all learned to live
with
there are no state or federal monies
that go towards
performing abortions and that's
something that's been made clear over
and over again
why we need to take it to the next level
why we need to have the finance
committee
make a policy decision on probably
next to gun positions
one of the most controversial things
this house deals with
i don't see why we want to put ourselves
in that position god knows we have
enough things else we can disagree on
so i guess what i'm asking is that we
not deal with either of these amendments
that we
find both of them inexpedient and we
stick with the language that's there
i'm sure i'm as equally as unhappy with
the languages there
as you are but at least isn't that what
they always say a good compromise is
is something that both sides aren't
happy with but they get up with
thank you thank you um are there any
uh other comments i i i have
comments to make but i i want to not
exceed my privilege here i i think we
this family planning money is in the
budget
the family planning program is something
i think
we can all agree on and in an effort to
agree on what we agree on i think
we all agree that um
having accessible and that means
financially and physically accessible
uh std checks and
family planning counseling for uh for
birth control
uh and the like are those are those are
good
societal investments
[Music]
i think the that most of the
clinics that accept the family planning
program money
historically have not also operated
under the same roof
as the i i
i i will refer to it as a reproductive
health facility even though personally i
think that's a tremendously orwellian
and inappropriate term for what
but abortion is a constitutionally
protected
medical procedure and although i'm
pro-life i'm also very pro-constitution
i i am not wanting to attack
the right of a woman to have an abortion
because
uh the constitutional arguments have
been
weighed and have held that a woman has
that right
certainly in the first trimester and so
so i was very comfortable with removing
what referred to as the gag order
because i
i i think it would be totally
inappropriate
to have a medical counselor presenting
a woman with all of her options on birth
control
and prohibited by the state
to speak about one of the options that
she may have should she
become pregnant so um
so i i i'm i'm on board with the notion
that it would be inappropriate to try to
ban
those kinds of communications
so where am i falling on this i'm
falling
on my background in radiology
administration
and understanding the stark act
and the purposes of the stark act dating
back 40 years
as kind of an anti-kickback program
and the basic premise of the
anti-kickback
law was that if a provider
was going to profit from the medical
referral
then that provider should not own
the facility that they refer to
and clearly planned parenthood
does not fall under the stark act but
i'm using it as an example to explain
the principle
that
the organization that's doing the
medical counseling
should not have a financial incentive
to skew their recommendations
towards one medical procedure over
another
and i think the value of a physical
and financial segregation is to
ensure that medical counseling
is done with the full focus on the woman
and
her and her family's needs without
being jaundiced possibly
by a profit incentive of referring
somebody
over to the abortion wing of the
facility
and so for
the principles of anti-kickback in the
principles of the stark act although not
legally applicable
the principle i think is still there and
so
i am actually in favor of this
stripped-down
amendment and um
and i think that uh
some current historical providers may
choose
not to provide continue to provide
service
they may choose not to compete for these
family planning dollars
but as we heard there were alternative
medical facilities
within two miles of every reproductive
health facility
taking a family planning contract and so
we have good reason to believe that
substitute providers will enter into the
competition
and maybe given that there's fresh
competition we might
actually benefit from
free market competition a little bit to
see if we can get
better overall services so i
i do think that this is a legitimate hb2
although there is a big policy issue
here i think there's also the financial
issue the financial issue is
you know should we accept
um yeah which what do we believe do we
believe that
competition will increase and improve
services
or do do we think that maintaining
uh what's become sort of a hardwired
non-competitive environment is the right
way to go
so so i i would i would like to
ask for support for this uh this
amendment zero nine
four zero h representative
rogers your hand is up yes i have a
question
so are you saying that you actually
believe that the
family health clinics are making a
profit
off abortions and so they're counseling
people
to get abortions as a form of birth
control
i don't think it's that direct i think
there's wide belief
that money is fungible and that the
money
that is funding the the
the side of the accounts dealing with
family planning and family planning
counseling
are not directly paying for abortion but
given that they're being offered by the
same provider
it is recognized in the principles of
the stark act that there should be uh
separation within the referral pattern
and and i i think that's been accepted
for 40 years
it's barred orthopedic surgeons for
example
from owning their own radiology services
so if somebody comes in with a broken
arm
the orthopedic surgeon needs to refer to
an independent radiology
business and not just refer to
themselves in their own
owned equipment and so
uh i i think the spirit of
of separating an orthopedic surgeon from
owning radiology equipment
is not that different in
concept from requiring a separation from
a family planning
counselor from um the provision of the
abortion
that that that's what i believe i would
just caution you
um if i could follow up on this um yes
yeah
no we're having a conversation neither
bill has been introduced so we're just
we're just talking i guess i would would
ask you to
to go to one of these clinics first of
all
if you if you've ever not if you've ever
been to one
um i'd ask you to go again and talk to
some of the women that are patients
there
um if you have an abortion it's far
different
than having an orthopedic surgeon work
on your arm or your
leg it's a far harder decision
and it's a far different feeling than
having someone
operate on you as as any other thing
that would happen it's something that
fortunately representative edwards
you would never have to deal with but um
people that work in these clinics first
of all have to suffer with wondering if
they're going to be bombed
wondering if someone's going to shoot
them when they leave often going through
picket lines when they get in to go to
work
and the people that they deal with they
work very hard to counsel them with a
lot of things
and i assure you that abortion is one of
the last things
that a woman does when they're under
these situations
and it's not something that they counsel
someone to do
to make a profit um there's a lot of
other things
that goes on at this clinic other than
abortions
and a lot of other things to save
women's lives that happen
and to have an abortion and to liken
having abortion
having surgery on your arm is is
very very wrong kind of
likeness it's very different
i do appreciate that as an attorney you
understand
that probably understand the distinction
in the analogies
my analogy is for the anti-kickback
incentive of the counselor not
the very difficult decision of the woman
that's why i'm perfectly good with
removing
the gag order so that they can receive
women can receive counseling on their
full range of options so that they can
make that very difficult decision in an
informed way what i'm what i think this
amendment does is it removes
the the hidden finger on the scale of
counseling
to make sure that the counseling is
offered without a profit
incentive to bias their
counseling potentially but what if you
ask me
you asked me to go visit a
family practice or excuse me a
reproductive health facility and
and i did as a member of hhs go spend
time
with uh on the honorable pauli
uh campion and i think
representative uh mary kay
um oh god it's killing me that i'm
missing their last name
but anyways i have gone and i met
miss kyla montgomery there and we spent
a lot of time
talking about it and if as i remember i
recommended to them that they do a much
better job
of advertising and marketing the fact
that they're providing std services
and to report to the public in a more
transparent way
what the trends were so that people's
behavior could be modified by the
information i
gave them some advice on how to make
their services
more useful to the society so i've been
there
and although i'm pro-life
i am also sworn to protect
this medical procedure so um
on on a personal level the first time i
went into an abortion center was as a
young man
and when i was a never mind i'm going to
tell that story but
it's a personal story where this is a
very real
issue to me and as a father of two
daughters
it's a brother of four sisters i don't
i don't minimize or take lightly the
difficulty of the decision
that the woman has to make what i'm what
this
amendment does is it doesn't affect the
woman's choice
at all it affects
who is providing the family planning
counselor and it's doing it on the basis
of
ensuring that there is no financial
incentive to counsel more in one
direction than another
your hand is up dude yeah if i could
make this one last point is
i said it's not just the woman that's
there the counselors
have to work in an environment that is
as
we can see from around the country quite
often a target
for not only protests but violent
protests for bombing
for all kinds of things so they are
under a lot of pressure
and they are not given an incentive they
do not make bonuses for the amount of
abortions
that they they counsel people to have
they are not
told to counsel people to have abortions
there's no finger on the scale
these are counselors that are committed
to being
um helpful to women they're committed to
their cause so to speak
for women's health so um it's not a
business
it's it's something that they are
committed to and they're committed to
women's health
so um that's why i have a little bit of
a problem with this and i also do think
it's an impossibility for the ones that
exist to ask them to build a new
facility
so that it's physically separate is an
impossible situation for them to make
so while i appreciate your intent i
think that this will in fact
put some people out of business and i'm
not so sure that there will be other
competition
or that we will not limit women's
accessibility in other states this kind
of thing
going into statute has in fact limited
the amount of places
and in some states actually um and i'm
forgetting the state right now but it's
one state that it and my understanding
is it
actually um took away any center where
someone
could get an abortion in the state they
had to go elsewhere so
i thank you for for your intentions and
i guess we just have to agree to have
opposing views here
right and and um i
obviously no one is going to change
anyone's mind
in this discussion you know that i think
our objective
is to be clear on our own positions so
that
that those positions can be understood i
i think we're long past
changing anyone's mind on this
particular topic
and you've twice mentioned the threat of
violence
in um and the threat of violence in any
situation
is is potentially there and
uh many years ago in another part of the
country there
there was in fact some violence but i
think we're very fortunate that we've
never experienced that sort of thing in
new hampshire
so at least not that i know of rep
representative nordgren
thank you mr chair i would just um
piggyback on what representative rogers
is saying
and i think one of my big concerns will
be
the north country and the parts of the
state that are
already underserved by all medical
professions and i think that could this
could bring an
extra burden to that part of the
population
of new hampshire so i think that should
be a concern in our discussion
thank you can i share your concern
and it was my understanding from mr
tierney's uh
testimony that uh the the
what we'll call the northern providers
uh
we're not also providing um
the reproductive health facility
services i.e
outpatient abortion centers that they
they that they were providing family
planning without the abortions and if a
woman
chose an abortion the referral would
have to be down to concord or
another place performing the procedure
in the state
so i i don't know that this is is a risk
at all
to those facilities because they've been
receiving family planning money they'd
continue to get family planning money
and
potentially because we're reopening this
up to a more
aggressive competition you know maybe
maybe we'll have more money to stretch
further
your hand is still up i don't know if
you want to respond
could i just please react to your
comment i resentment
no we're having a conversation please do
okay i resent
your characterization of
abortion
buildings i mean i think that's
not the context we're talking about
thank you i i i accept your resentment
sorry so um
is there any further discussion on this
um i i i would entertain a motion
amendment2021-0940h
i would move that we recommend amendment
0940h to hb
two to replace section 34.
is there a second seconded by
representative weiler
being moved and seconded is there uh
not saying in this any discussion mr
chair or mr clerk would you please take
okay for amendment 09408
if you're in favor of accepting the
adopting the amendment you'll say yes if
you're opposed you'll say no
representative earth
yes representative weiler votes yes
representative bean
yes representative walnut
no representative nordgren
no representative rogers
no representative edwards
yes mr the vote is four
to three thank you
um now um mr ripple
as i understand the procedures we have
no need
to discuss or vote on the
leon amendment we could having passed
this amendment we can
move on that's correct
if no one offers the other amendment you
don't need to do anything with it
okay is there anyone wanting to offer
the leon amendment for a
not seeing any um i think what we can do
at this point
is move on to hb1 to take a look at the
family planning lines
uh in general we have representative irf
who's
done some analysis representative rogers
who's done some analysis
and in general what what i understand to
be the case
is that when the previous federal
administration was in
office they
removed funds from
at the federal level and that the state
and the current budget year decided that
it would be
good to invest enough money
to fill that gap and
the expectation is that the current
federal administration
will return to the previous policy of
direct funding
um reproductive health facilities
uh and so so there's an issue
of what should we be doing with the
general funds
given that the availability of federal
funds
is going to be different in the current
in the future
in the next budget that we're working on
relative to the current budget that
we're in
and so with that as a backdrop uh
representative ruer for you
um can you are you able to share your
screen as mr ripple let you
do that or is he sharing your screen or
how's that working
mr ripple has all the information let me
just pull it up here
did you want me to start with the
amendment itself representative
uh yes please miss ripple
[Music]
this might be yeah this is the wrong one
hold on a sec
so this proposal funds the family
planning budget
at what it has been historically
preceding bienniums
and accounts for the actual spending in
2016 the actual spending was one million
one hundred sixty eight thousand four
hundred and twelve dollars
in 2018 the actual spending was one
million
two hundred sixty thousand nine hundred
forty six dollars
this budget is one million forty two
thousand
six hundred forty three dollars in fy
twenty two
and one million fifty four thousand four
and seventeen dollars
in fy twenty three the federal title ten
allotment for new hampshire
is 800 000 while recent budgets have
included a much
much larger amount six hundred thousand
dollars of that
has not flowed through new hampshire but
went directly to planned parenthood
in new hampshire title 10 funding can be
used for overhead
and pharmaceuticals in addition to
family planning services
in the recent past medicaid funding
for family planning services was
expanded
miners now qualify for medicaid family
planning
funding based on their own income and
not that of their parents
this means essentially all miners
qualify for medicaid
family planning services which are
independent of the title 10 services
at the same time the income threshold
for adults to qualify
for medicaid funding for family planning
services
increased in a manner similar to that
for the expanded medicaid for health
care
this means many more adults also qualify
for medicaid
family planning services this means
clinics have two
revenue streams supporting family
planning services medicaid funding
which comes directly from the federal
government and title 10 funding
which in new hampshire can come by the
state
or planned parenthood medicaid funding
covers family planning services without
limit while clinics can use their title
10 funding
to cover their overhead and
pharmaceuticals
this can be seen in the recent family
planning contracts approved by the
executive council
but the services component of the
contracts has trended down
as that is covered by medicaid in
addition
recent changes allowing for the use of
telehealth and providing family planning
services
and a change in prescribing
pharmaceuticals allowing for 12-month
prescriptions
rather than three months means cost of
services have decreased as well
the net effect is that new hampshire
need not be as financially involved
with the provision of family planning
services as it has been
in fact our neighboring state of maine
in our neighboring state of maine the
state is not involved at
all with title 10 funding that funding
flows directly to family planning
association of maine
inc
and there is the budget that you could i
just described to you that kevin's got
up on the uh
screen so i'm i if you could mr rip will
highlight some of the key numbers here
so we
so in fy 22
it looks like the governor's bill is
introduced to the house
had 2.977 million dollars in the
governor's budget
is am i reading that right yes
representative irf is recommending a
reduction of 1.934 million
for a net of 1.042 million in general
funds
for fy22
uh that's the total appropriation the
general funds are
down here do you
so so representative erf i i
i can understand the basic construct
that the federal money was not available
in the
in the prior in the current budget and
so new hampshire
stepped up its contribution to make up
for the gap
and i can accept the concept that now
that the federal
government's going to step back in with
its funding new hampshire no longer
needs to continue to provide that gap
i'm having a hard time seeing these
numbers and
matching it to those two concepts
can you help me with that
i no i don't understand what you're
asking so
if you go back as i said to 2016
and 2018 the family planning budgets
were comparable to what
i have there in that budget if you're
only looking at the current biennium
you're looking at basically you'll
notice there's two lines there now 102
and 103.
103 did not exist prior to this current
biennium
and what happened was in when we
as you indicated the at the time
the federal government was preventing
monies going to planned parenthood
through title 10 funding
you'll notice though that the number
there for the 102 line
that's pretty much the same in other
words that didn't change
from other from the biennium before from
the years by name before or
to my proposal in this biennium what
happened was 1.6 million dollars was
added in per year
to get around the federal title 10
restrictions
now in fact i think we may recall that
miss
rounds told us that in fact that 1.6
million is not
what flowed through the state of new
hampshire eight hundred thousand dollars
flows to the state of new hampshire same
as the eight hundred thousand dollars on
that's in the budget that i've proposed
the other money and i don't actually
even believe it was necessarily a
thousand dollars i think it might have
been 800
600 000 but in any case that money went
directly to planned parenthood
so it's a little difficult to compare
apples to apples for on the one hand
on the other hand the budget doubled
essentially even if you exclude the 600
directly to planned parenthood the
budget doubled
in this most current biennium from the
biennium's prior to that
and all we're doing all i'm proposing is
that we bring it back to
the way it was budgeted prior to the
current biennium
representative question
thank you mr chair i was wondering if
um maybe kayla from planned parenthood
is on
if she could comment i i thought there
was
a large gap between when our funding
ends and the feds take over again
so i'd just like a clarification on that
please
so so let's let representative rogers do
her her piece and if we still need
somebody so a participant then then we
can consider it that
at that point because representative
rogers may have the answer you're
looking for
hey thank you representative rogers
are you and mr ripple prepared to
to show your version i believe he has
basically what my amendment does is um
fills the gap that representative earth
says doesn't exist
um it is true that the federal monies
the biden administrationist says that
that the federal gag rule is going to be
lifted
and the federal monies will in fact come
back however
the federal monies won't flow back into
the state for
probably approximately nine months so
there will be a nine month gap so the
amount that i've put in here in the
general funds
um would certainly get us through those
nine months
when the federal monies will not be
coming
and that's why i've increased the lines
in the general fund to cover that amount
of time
and two years ago yes it's true we did
increase the general fund
but that was in his in the anticipation
of the federal funds
decreasing and also as i said
previously the fact that we are in the
midst of
and we were two years ago
[Music]
epidemic of stds and these
family planning clinics were doing as i
said 97
of the testing on these stds and
they in fact had grown at the amount of
exorbitant i can't remember the exact
percentage two years ago but
the stds had grown an exorbitant amount
very fast
and the department was quite concerned
about this epidemic of the stds we
wanted to try to get a handle on it
and there was no funding in any place
else for it
so we wanted to try to deal with that
which is part of the reason
that we increased the funding um was to
deal with that that epidemic that was
going on
so there was a large jump to deal with
those two things
along with the anticipation of the
cutback in the federal funds and in fact
those federal funds did decrease and
were not
gained during that time if you recall
carrie runs did tell us that the federal
money actually
shouldn't be in this budget that it goes
to the centers directly
and she'd put it in here for us to see
what it amounted to
but it does go to the clinics all
separately as my understanding
but this figure that i've got is for a
nine-month period of time
and hopefully we'll cover the clinics
until that federal money
comes in can you ask your question about
that
sure i'll try to answer okay so
so i'm i'm trying to process what you're
saying and what i would expect
to see on line 103
is that first
1.6 million we're thinking
isn't going to start well wait a second
if 1.6 million is a year why would nine
months be 1.2 million
these are the numbers that i got from um
the the folks in the family planning um
clinics that this was the amount they
would need to get through the nine
months
i got numbers from them for three months
six months and nine months so
um and i decided to go for nine months
since it was the time i needed
um so i can't break it down for you this
was the number i reached out to get
and this is what i came back with and
so do we expect the current
administration
to be more generous in its family
planning
spending than what occurred before the
previous administration i i don't know
whether they will be or not i think that
that's something we're all waiting to
see
um i think it'll be more more generous
obviously than the
um last four years but if you're asking
me if it will be more generous than the
four years prior to that
i i think that that would be just
conjecture
if you have questions representative
verb i'm sorry
i heard some speaking but i said it
would just be like
blind guessing on my part to answer that
representative questions
well just a couple of points i actually
don't understand what this gap is that's
being referred to
but the current title 10 family planning
grants made in 2019
apply through march 31st of 2022 that'd
be next year
that's one point so i'm not sure what
what what the gap is
the other point though is that all std
testing
is free under medicaid which is
completely independent
okay i
i think i would benefit if
representative rogers and representative
irf
talked to each other and bounced their
numbers around and then we revisited
this tomorrow
i i i i i i'm not really doing a good
job with sort of the dueling
spreadsheets and i have to look at them
both and
think about them as representative irf
and representative rogers
are you willing to spend some time today
to
to try to compare notes and figure out
sure
i'd be happy to speak with
representative rogers we're in
two very different places just beginning
we didn't begin from the same place
yes sir that that's why i asked you to
figure out what you can agree to agree
on
okay okay so uh so i
i just i i unders i take it as a given
that there's going to be disagreement
i think it would benefit the committee
if you guys were able to explain to us
what you can agree to agree on on this
and then what the distinctions are
between you and and then i think we'd be
all right so
okay i think we're ready to look at that
hb2
on um on the legacy of the mms legacy
okay and this is not numbered this would
be a new hb2
representative norgren did i miss you
okay
well i think i may have misnumbered the
mmi